if you've been watching of their news
anchors and pundits over the last day
you may think they sound like a bunch of
kids on Christmas Eve now why am I
saying that you made it to Friday it is
the beginning of the Labor Day weekend
and talk heating up that special counsel
Robert Muller could drop an August
surprise Axios looking at speculation
over whether Bob Muller may actually
make some sort of an announcement today
hot speculation among the president's
lawyers that today might be a day of
action for Robert Moore well today is
not quite over yet but it's a nice
serving of wild unsourced speculation on
a Friday come on guys the news isn't
that boring today is a lot happening
what are the president's critics
grasping at any straws over the Muller
probe at this point joining us now to
analyze is Alan Dershowitz author of the
big bestseller the case against
impeaching Trump we're also joined by
Kendall Coffey a former US attorney
great to see both of you professor
Dershowitz that is quite amusing I've
been hearing that it's coming it's
coming there's something coming I don't
think Muller as the office is leaking
anything they've been pretty you know
they've been pretty tight so it's just
you know a case of desperate wishful
thinking on the part of the media I
think they thought that we're now two
months away from the beginning really of
the elections and Justice Department
regulations say you shouldn't have
matters that might interfere with voting
or interfere with the election to put a
thumb on the scale of voting within two
months so this was a time when maybe
something would have happened but look I
think today what's happened is news
reporting has become part of the
adversary system Kendall and I are used
to the adversary system he's one of the
world's great lawyers he was my lawyer
in fact and he and I both understand the
adversary system one side presents its
view of the facts the other side
presents its view of the facts then you
have a judge or a jury design that's
what's happening with journalism today
and wishful thinking substitutes often
for careful analysis Kendall we're going
to play we have a couple different
George Stephanopoulos sound bites we'll
play the second one where again he's
this guy's been around for a while now
used to wear
for the clintons obviously but he's been
around for a while but this is what
constitutes reporting today let's watch
the New York Attorney General has filed
suit against the Trump foundation which
could lead to a criminal referral the
Manhattan district attorney also
considering charges against the Trump
Organization Trump facing lawsuits in
Maryland and DC over the Constitution's
of monuments clause and of course
special counsel robert muller
investigating possible collusion with
russia and obstruction of justice the
big question going fordable any of these
investigations laid the groundwork for
impeachment proceedings in congress
nothing's changed nothing's changed and
we're reporting it breathlessly like
this is all new stuff
kendall yeah I've never seen a
speculation becomes so intoxicating to
the media I have to say by the way is in
a cite Alan Dershowitz is the greatest
legal town in America and a personal
hero of mine too much you guys are too
Alan is Alan speaks for himself he's
magnificent but let me talk about the
election because they're not supposed to
drop bombshells on the midterm who knows
if there's any bombshells
to drop and let's also recognize that
the election is coming up very fast if
there is a two-year standard a two-month
standard years ago early voting in
Florida pretty important state starts
around October 27th
overseas but absent ease go out next
month and by October beginning of
October domestic absent T's go out so I
don't think there's any bombshells that
they're rolling out anytime soon but
from the standpoint of avoiding
interference with an election I think
the deadline is passed all right
professor Dershowitz the guy who's
already in the middle of the Lanny Davis
Trump Tower stories anonymous source
controversy Jim sciutto who I named I
always mispronounced he also weighed in
on the speculation let's watch we've
used the term constitutional crisis and
that phrase has been uttered a number of
times and warned about on a number of
things what we in this environment
though would it really boot be received
that way right because arguably the
president has shirked constitutional
responsibilities certainly broken nor
a number of times frankly without
consequences broken registers now we're
at broken norms Alan well you know the
system of checks and balances is working
very very effectively the courts are
striking down some executive orders
upholding some the media is critical of
the president's I'm supporting the
president the Academy is generally
putting pressure against the president
churches business everybody's involved
in checking and balancing everybody else
democracy is working this is not a
constitutional crisis if the president
is subpoenaed he'll go to court and if
he goes to court he may win he may lose
and if he loses he'll comply with the
orders of the court this is the way
Madison had in mind when he created our
awkward system of checks and balances
which was not designed to promote
efficiency but to avoid tyranny it's
working
Oh Kendall I'd say I'm not sure Madison
had a special counsel in mind I might
beg to differ with the professor there I
don't know about that to me it seems
like this is this has gone way beyond a
check in about check and balance was
impeachment and conviction will Senate
I'm not sure special counsels what any
of our framers intended but why would
another country because I have you two
gentlemen here I'd like to get your
thought on another mullah related tip
two sources told Fox News is Catherine
Herridge the do J's Bruce or kept a
muller deputy in the loop about the
anti-trump Steele dossier so in other
words does that endanger Muellers
ethical standing I'll go to I'll go to
Kendall on that well it's it's troubling
isn't it I mean if you think about and
whether it's flashes over to Bob mowers
a different question but it's obviously
Bruce's wife was working for a private
company funded by Democrats some of my
best friends are Democrats as it goes
but nevertheless that is a glaring
conflict of interest and let
interactions he had with others which
were frankly outside of his immediate
duties is the director of OSA death
which focuses on drug trafficking
organizations is also included so it
a lot a lot of questions DOJ in my mind
has not done a satisfactory job of
explaining it they're really effective
at investigating others but when they go
under the microscope sometimes we don't
get a lot of clarity all right Alan at
the end of the week hear any more
thoughts on Bruce or was the closed-door
testimony this week but his name has
been occupying a lot of airtime for
obvious reasons with his connection with
Christopher Steele his wife of course
works at fusion GPS you know the drill
well I was prepared to give Bruce or the
presumption of innocence he was a
student at Harvard Law School everybody
tells me he's a really good guy and the
thing that really put me away from or
maybe overcame the pure presumption of
innocence is the presence of his wife at
a lunch or breakfast or whatever it was
meaning where obviously he was trying to
obtain information in an official
capacity and his wife was working for a
private company I do think that the
Inspector General now has to really look
into that relationship and I trust the
Inspector General I think he's one of
the very few people who comes away from
all of this looking very good and I
would leave it to the inspector general
to give us a thorough investigation or a
good answer as to the relationship
between Bruce or his wife the company
the Democrats the Justice Department
it's very complicated
all right gentlemen thank you so much